have you uh
seen the you've seen the polling data
probably more so than i on uh black
voters as it pertains to the democrats
moving forward and it's looking really
bad i hear is that is that correct yeah
well it's down blacks are still the only
major demographic where where biden is
still above water and by the way since
you brought this up there's this
business about
drop kicking biden kamala harris in
favor of somebody else because their
poll numbers are so bad common harris's
are worse than uh than joe biden's
never going to happen the nominee in
2024 on the democratic side will be
kamala harris really joe biden can't
make it they have no choice black people
are the most loyal part of the
democratic base and black women are more
loyal than black men and her approval
among black females is probably in the
mid 70s and if they perceive carmel
harris to be dropkicked for somebody
else especially a white man after for
decades they've indoctrinated black
people into believing when you criticize
a black person often the criticism is
because of sexism and racism they cannot
do that they painted themselves into a
corner the only way kamala harris leaves
is if she says i want to leave i'm not
competent i want somebody else to take
my place and she's not going to do that
because she ran for president but have
you heard the theories that she'll take
some prestigious offer or a ngo or
something or a big deal only only if she
says okay i want to leave voluntarily
but if she's perceived as being kicked
out they will black women will not they
will not vote republican they just won't
vote but so so even outside of that um
it's looking like the polling has gotten
so bad they say
if democrats lose i think uh they need
at least 80 percent of the black vote in
order to win right if the polling for
them
uh if the polling for republicans rises
above 20 or something like that like the
democrats lose out right and that's it's
looking like we're there that's right
because the democrats have lost the
white vote since 1964. they rely on
convincing black people that the issue
is social justice not crime not schools
not breakdown of the family but but the
fact that there's systemic racism and
democrats have convinced black people
that that's the number one problem
facing america but something weird is
happening the democratic party got
whiter in the past couple of years and
wealthier right it's like they're
abandoning that they've always been yeah
there's a book called who really cares
by a guy named arthur c brooks
he was he was a
public policy professor at syracuse he
wasn't even particularly conservative
and he found out nobody ever done
extensive study on whether or not
liberals or conservatives were more
generous or less generous so he did a
study and he found out much to his
surprise that conservatives were far
more generous with their time and with
their money than liberals uh contrary to
what he thought and it's for two reasons
first of all conservatives are more
religious than uh than liberals
religious
liberals give just as much money as
religious conservatives do but they're
just fewer of them and secondly most
conservatives believe that welfare
should be done people-to-people church
to church organization organization not
government and they walk the walk and
talk the talk and so it's really
interesting how a lot of black people
perceive the republicans to be only
concerned about money when in fact
they're more generous with their time
and with their money than liberals are
what do you think is going to happen in
uh
in the midterms or in 2024 with uh with
particularly with the black folk but i'm
wondering if this precipitates just well
i think republicans are spiking the
football a little early on the midterms
uh because inflation's getting a little
bit better the gas prices are getting a
little bit better and they were able to
spend the jobs report even though most
of these jobs that were created the last
month were part-time jobs and the media
is still in bed with joe biden they
can't stand republicans they fear
deathly fear that donald trump would
rear his ugly head in 2024 and so no
matter what it is they spin it uh in
favor of joe biden i mean the guy
doesn't even know where he is
uh and the hunter biden story has been
suppressed still and they're not
connecting the dots it's not about
hunter biden's crack habit i don't care
about that i care about whether or not
joe biden is compromised and apparently
he is yeah what what i i've been saying
this man people
they look at the historical trends where
the president's party loses seats in
their first term
they're looking at this the the the
misery index saying democrats are going
to get crushed and then there are some
polls that just came out recently in
aggregate showing that the the race is
tightened that republicans so for for
months we're talking about how
republicans were up three three points
in the generic ballot which is
apocalyptic for democrats now it's like
point one
or even i think 538 has it inverted
democrats have took the lead again
that's right still historically that
should signal democrats losing but i'm
telling people if you look at that stuff
and you think that means you know uh
if if you're looking at all this stuff
and you think you've got in the bag you
don't people need to go out and act as
though no matter what the
no matter what the polls are you need to
get three or even ten of your friends to
go out and vote yeah we're treating
biden right now like a like a toxic
boyfriend or girlfriend where it's like
i know i should break up with her but i
don't want to get back on tinder like
and it's like
we have to we have to hold them well we
don't know how the reversal of roe v
wade is going to play um right there
between now and then that seems to have
helped democrats it has yeah so if you
look at the real certainly help their
fundraising absolutely and if you look
at real clear politics you can see that
the gap just closed from democrats to
republicans in aggregate this is not one
single pole yeah and again i don't even
know if i'm a democrat anymore you guys
i've been calling myself a bleeding
heart centrist but i will say like four
liberals listening
you want to hold your party accountable
you want to have the best democratic
party that actually has values and
morals and isn't just a bunch of
corporate hacks you want the best
for your party you don't want to just
blindly support a president who's doing
a terrible job because that is bad for
the future of the party that's bad for
you but who are you talking to i don't
know man there's another person out
there like me somewhere listening you
just changed somebody's life yeah i hope
so i feel like for you you had to get
thrown to the wolves by the left before
you finally well that's why i'm trying
to help everybody listening it's like
guys don't rock bottom like me don't let
your life be destroyed before you're
like maybe i should have a republican
friend just one because they'll be like
i don't care about your politics and i'm
like oh we can just hang out and play
basketball what was the spark where you
realized something was amiss
i mean i did before
my
life fell apart it was when i would hang
out with prominent liberals and they
would talk a certain way and say that
certain things were silly and then they
would go to their twitter and say the
opposite and that's why i'm like oh
we're
we're lying um it was when the first
time i talked to people who were more
conservative or libertarians
were people of color
at my jujitsu gym where when i went to
like staff meetings of liberal
publications their get-togethers in like
park slope brooklyn it was very very
white and very very privileged like hey
all that stuff you're saying it applies
to this room and they're like shut up
yeah yeah get out but it was that it was
they'll be tweeting about black lives
matter is they're walking down the
street and they're like oh black person
across the street across the street
across the street like it was just uh it
was the hypocrisy this is sweden in my
experience to the tea because i went to
sweden do you remember that uh when
donald trump said you know the last
night in sweden thing
do you remember that so this was back in
2017 there was a documentary that came
up on fox or like a short talking about
crime going up in sweden
i i go there
and i find that a lot of the claims are
largely exaggerated and didn't
understand the complexities of sweden
but what i did find is that people in
sweden are
so many of them not all of them but so
much of their culture was very much in
advance of how the us was
they are over like their scandinavian
white people talking about how not
racist they are and then trying
everything in their power to keep black
people away from them because they were
just
they they wanted people to think they
weren't racist
but they were really racist but i should
also say maybe that's actually wrong
maybe i should say culturalist
because they didn't like people who
didn't speak their language they didn't
like people who didn't look like them so
it was not just race it was even even
white people who didn't speak you know
swedish they'd be like well we don't
want to work with you it's just we don't
we don't want you around they're just
d-bags in general i'm thinking like if
you're raised if i was raised in like a
tribe in africa with people with darker
skin tone or whatever that i then i
would be weirded out by people with
light skin tone if i saw not necessarily
weirded out but like it's a familiarity
bias i don't even know what racism is
like i think racism small r and racism
big r big r is where you're like you're
different than me it's you know racial
slur and where a small r
maybe is more classist i don't know but
but this again this is america this is
the only majority white country that's
elected the black president there is a
sociologist at harvard all sociologists
are left-wing his name is his name is
orlando patterson he's black and in the
90s he says america is the least racist
majority white society in the world
provides more opportunities for blacks
than any society in the world including
all of those of africa
when my i want to tell you a quick story
jamie when my when my race was over
i'm in a restaurant in la on the west
side and i get there and my buddy hasn't
arrived yet and there's a table next to
me with two ladies and i think they feel
sorry for me yeah so they started
talking to me
and they were 85 years old they'd known
each other since the second grade they
were jewish one was a human rights
activist whatever that mean the other
one was a psychotherapist yeah
and then about 15 minutes after the
conversation one of them said wait a
minute i know who you are
you're that guy that ran for governor
i said that's right and she had a big
smile she said guess who i voted for so
you didn't vote for me
and she said how do you know that i said
let's see uh we're in the west side of
l.a you're both jewish one of you is a
human rights activist it doesn't take
humble to put that together you didn't
vote for me and she said no you're right
i didn't i said how do you feel about
the about the crime and she said i have
a friend who got mugged and told me
about that that's how you feel about the
quality of our schools she said i would
never put my kids in a public school how
do you feel about the way gavin newsom
shut down the state in a more severe way
than anybody else did sitting up there
at that restaurant not wearing a mask
not engaging in social differences with
the people that drafted the mandates had
his own kids in person she said i
thought was hypocritical how do you feel
about the fact that people leaving
california so they agree with me on
everything
i said so here we are completing each
other's sentences yet you wouldn't vote
for me do you have any republican
friends at all and they look at each
other and they admit that they didn't
they said this is the first time you've
ever had a conversation with somebody
who's conservative isn't it and they
both said yes i mean honestly yeah talk
about they talk about you just in a
cocoon you should just call them racist
bigots all those things you said were
conservative alt-right talking and then
be like buy my book and just throw it
and then and then they bought my drinks
and bought my dinner yeah that's what i
wanted well and and that's the thing i
ordered lobster i think i was lobster of
course
i don't even like lobsters
yeah i think one of the most insidious
words um
is when if you change your mind you're
called a grifter and i've made jokes
about this i've made jokes about it on
cass castle um on the podcast because
essentially it's saying that
if you evolve a viewpoint if you step
out of your bubble if you you know i
mean i didn't i expected when i came on
this show
that i would just kind of be like token
liberal guy make jokes um make fun of
myself all done and i've been
fascinated at
how my a lot of my views have changed
and not because you know tim hired me
when i was like liberal liberal liberal
um
my views have changed because i'm just
talking to different people which we
should all be doing and in fact when i
talk to some conservative friends and i
still give some of my bleeding heart
points of view they go oh man i never
thought of that either and that's good
as well you're not grifting you're
growing this is what i try to explain to
people you're you're searching for the
truth i'm searching for the truth that's
what you are yes and if you have that i
don't care if you're a republican
malcolm x said i'm for the truth no
matter who's telling it yes and that's
how i feel yep i i'm willing to change
my mind make me change my give me the
facts give me something i've said wrong
thought wrong and i will change my mind
my god i got excited when you quoted
malcolm x okay you know let's get back
in focus one thing you've got to be
careful of is love bombs from getting
this new crowd of followers oh we talked
about that with the marjorie taylor
green where uh every time now uh i got a
compliment they're like we're love
bombing you jamie and i'm like i know
because it feels good to get accepted it
does
well and and look man i still see a lot
of stuff i'll tweet like an innocuous
joke about you know something i saw that
day and you know i know people who found
me on here like will just start like
ranting about biden and i'm like okay
bud like you can take it down i'm not a
biden fan but i think that look when you
start changing your mind because you're
being accepted no good if you're doing
it for a paycheck that's where the term
grifter makes sense if you are asking
questions to people on the left and to
people on the right and your only goal
like you said larry is just to find the
truth or like dude i just want people to
start coming up with solutions and i
know that if we're screaming at that's
why my questions to you
were all about like hey how do we get
people to talk about this hey take
politics out what do you what are you
telling someone who's struggling how do
you act as a man like forget what party
you are let me let me actually ask you
then i guess
the next step in the question of
solutions
if the perception is that people are
unwilling to listen they're
hyper-tribalized your friends of 40
years i think you said was it 40 years
wouldn't even read an article
where do you think this is all heading
well
there's a certain percentage of people
that you have to write off
they will not listen they do not care uh
they're locked into their positions i'm
not sure what the percentage of that is
there was a 2002 fox opinion poll eight
percent of americans believe elvis is
still alive
six percent belief if you send him a
letter he'll get it now it seems to me
that eight percent just gotta you just
gotta white you know just write him off
i think most people are pursuing their
own
own owned uh personal interest
they want to realize their god-given
potential i think most people do that
and if you are persistent and you say
things in a persuasive in a persuasive
way
simply i think most people will at least
listen to you at least i operate under
that assumption and you have to operate
under that assumption other than what
how do you get up in the morning and
just go half the country is is is
irredeemable
i'm going to avoid that right i just
can't do that and i won't do that you
guys said earlier like the truth that
you're both seeking the truth i get
nervous about that because i feel like
it's subjective to um and that there's
no absolute truth it's facts you could
say there are facts but the way you look
at the fact is the your version of the
fact well either either either donald
trump mocked the handicap reporter or he
didn't either donald trump said there
were good nazis and bad nazis in
charlottesville or he didn't these are
just facts he did not do that he did not
mock a reporter yet yet much of the
country believes that uh
i don't believe in this i'll tell you my
truth there is a truth uh often it's
hard to find and often things are gray
but there are certain things that happen
and didn't happen two plus two equal
four i don't care how how you feel well
wait a second what's your second order
three and then it's i think it's what
your sexual orientation is two plus two
still equals four yeah i think that um
you know
a piece of relationship advice i
actually give that i think we could
really use when it comes to politics is
if me and ian are in a relationship and
we get in a fight and all i want to do
is prove that ian's wrong and all he
wants to do is prove that i'm wrong
nothing's going to get accomplished you
know even sometimes by the time let's
say i apologized then maybe even ian
throws in something like yeah we should
apologize you really hurt me i was like
oh man we're still going and i think
that if you're in a fight with your
girlfriend or boyfriend or whoever
if
you can just focus on hey what can i
what could i have done better even if
i'm in even if clearly my girlfriend was
in the wrong right right and i'm just
like well i guess i could have reacted
better and then i get to bring that to
the table and she brings that what she
did wrong to the table now we both grow
i wish
that republicans could hold themselves
accountable more liberals could hold
themselves accountable more and instead
of just attack attack attack it could
just be hey how do we get better and
again i don't even i think you got to
listen to the people you don't like
that's what it is it's heroic of course
like the truth is factual but the way
people feel is how you convince so
people want to i think some people maybe
want to just lay it on the facts and be
like this is the truth but if you don't
feel what they feel about it then it's
not the word true doesn't really ring
you have to connect with them on like a
human level i think i'm sure you've
learned that in years of of radio and
speaking where it's yeah if you're just
shouting facts at someone who disagrees
with you you're right they could totally
tune out but if you can actually connect
with them as a person through like
stories like the stories you tell about
your friends i go oh i've had a friend
i've had to walk away from from that and
you feel it you can connect to it and
then you can listen
my mom used to say the truth will not
set you free if delivered without hope
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there